because 29 teams had rookie mini camps
over the weekend and participation was
100 or damn close to it we'll talk about
that dynamic coming up later in the
program
here we go though with the team that has
the first overall pick had the first
overall pick in the draft made it
quarterback trevor lawrence recovering
from off-season shoulder surgery to his
non-throwing shoulder
he's able to throw the football though
here he is talking about the limitations
the team has placed on him as he
continues to recover from that procedure
what's been different for you or has it
been difficult to be on a pitch count
yeah i mean uh
it's you know i really appreciate the
staff here just looking out for my best
interest trying to slowly get me back in
in game shape and throwing shape for
practice so i can go out there full go
whenever the whole team's back together
so
that's been good for me it's a little
for me i want to get out there and just
and just throw and go but
i think it's better for me in the long
run just to take it slow and get
acclimated just because still recovering
from my left shoulder it's feeling great
no complaints here making great progress
but still gotta just be smart and take
it easy but yeah i'm wanting to go out
there and throw a lot but we're keeping
it you know around 30 to 40 balls not
including the warm up so
keeping it light just to make sure i'm
feeling good
he's already emulating one of the
all-time greats did you notice that
no what hell who he's he's got the
peyton manning red forehead from wearing
a helmet he definitely he's got a lot of
he's got a lot of peyton i i believe in
him i really do that's who i kind of see
when i when i look at trevor lawrence
some of the mannerisms you know
i don't know he's got a big forehead
like you're talking about a longer neck
like peyton kind of the way he handles
himself he wears that 16 so yeah i hear
you all the way i mean that that's the
guy no doubt
now that's the ultimate photoshop job
peyton manning with the long flowing
hair that would be something i assume
during his stint on snl maybe at some
point he had a wig on that would give
him that same look but that big old red
splotch i don't get it i don't
understand it i don't remember seeing a
red splotch on his head at clemson but
maybe that's part of the right the new
helmet to the nfl the red splotch that
says peyton manning all over it um look
he he's got to be ahead of schedule and
i think he mentioned he is ahead of
schedule because when he had the surgery
they're saying five to six months before
he could really do anything so they're
being careful they're being deliberate
they're getting him out there on the
field that there's no competition for
him other than guardian dementia i'm
telling you my theory on tim tebow to
the extent that this is a sideshow a
money grab you want to sell some tebow
jerseys you got to get rid of the guy
that's currently wearing number 15
before you can do that
and and and that's currently the only
real competition on the roster for
trevor lawrence there's no way he's not
the starter week one no like with zach
wilson in new york there's no way no no
it's it's it's written in stone you're
right there's no doubt about it with
that situation as far as
how the the quarterback position that
room is on their roster
uh everything around it yes just like
zach wilson they're starting day one
there's no competition they get the
first team reps and trevor lawrence will
get that i mean i think they're being
smart by taking it slow with the
shoulder thing and everything like that
listen it's his left shoulder right mike
so yeah it's not like there's a direct
impact of him you know affecting that
throwing the ball with his right hand
and his left shoulder but still hey it
is
recently you know surgically repaired so
maybe they do want to just limit the
wear and tear of when you're kind of you
know pulling that shoulder out of the
way to throw the football that aspect of
it but i'll tell you i think the biggest
thing that i thought of when they said
pitch count more than anything is yeah
pitch count because
forget this surgically repaired shoulder
he hasn't thrown the ball much
since he played the national
championship game and had his pro day
and this is the time of the year if you
come back and start throwing 180 220
balls a day all of a sudden mike in my
experience that's when you go a month
from now you start to go man my elbow
hurts you know i don't know every time i
grab something or every time i let go of
the ball i get a little weird tinge in
my elbow that's how you can really tire
your arm out and get arthritis and those
type of things like we've seen
brett favre kind of deal with through
the years so i think it's smart from
that aspect to get it in shape too
one thing that i noticed
in the footage of him throwing it looks
like a deliberate conscious effort it
looked like that right left arm tight to
the body yeah not let it flake right not
little so so they're get out of the way
and do that right
and i think urban meyer the jaguars
coach talked about that
some when he met with reporters this
week and keeping that left arm under
control i think that is a key to to
helping that that thing recover um as
relates to the number of passes thrown
though what
what if he's throwing 30 to 40 right now
right what's
what's the ideal number what what do you
want to get to you talked about an
extreme amount on the other end that
could cause a problem with the throwing
arm where does he need to be to be ready
to go for the week in and week out grind
right well like right now he's getting a
warm up he's getting loose he's getting
going then he gets to do probably some
of the individual routes and probably
the seven on seven reps but really to
become a machine as far as just a
machine within on your your own
mechanics knowing the offense you know
and everything like that hey i would say
like you know the really good
quarterbacks
on a given day it's going to be between
100 and 150 like real throws like a day
where you have otas you know or a mini
camp you know a mini camp you might have
two practices in a day where it might be
more than that but i think generally
that's what you're looking for you know
you want to get to the place to where
you get your arm in shape and as long as
you do things mechanically right you can
basically then now go wait i'm in shape
i'm doing things the right way
and now i can really
get a lot of reps and reps and reps and
reps and then that repetition starts to
you know get beaten into your hard wire
of your body and your muscles and
everything like that and that's when you
can become a machine like a rogers and
mahomes a peyton manning a brady to
where they're like a robot it doesn't
matter what that is so yeah right now
it's just good he's getting the reps mic
but like yeah not to the point to where
he's gonna need him and and really be
hitting on all cylinders like an nfl
starting quarterback
and they're working in that direction so
he's full go when training camp opens
and part of the challenge for them for
now
is to get him to remain fully bought in
because he wants to go and as phase two
of the offseason program begins today
the otas begin next week he is going to
be anxious to do more right gonna have
to hold him back but but there's much to
be learned because he's the guy week one
at houston he's the guy and they knew
drafting him that this was going to be
part of the plan this was part of the
reality he was coming off of that
surgery and and they're taking the smart
view and i think for now he's all in
with it he understands and the fact that
he doesn't have any real competition
reduces that urgency
if if he really did have to climb the
depth chart like some of these other
young quarterbacks are going to have to
do
then i think they'd have a very
difficult time chris getting trevor
lawrence to sign off on 30 or 40 passes
a day at this point you're right it adds
a little flexibility to the situation
and the player yeah is not chomping at
the bit knowing that he's going to be
judged on like i need to get out there i
need to compete i need to be playing at
you know my highest level here for me to
win the the starting job and then you do
you know start to push the training
staff and the coach for more reps and
that could end too like i was talking
about the tendonitis or anything like
that with you know the the the throwing
arm whatever so there's no rush there we
know he's the man you're the man trevor
jacksonville do things right like let's
not forget jacksonville's the
organization who needed to see dante
fowler come off the edge at full speed
remember that mic like six years ago on
the first day of rookie mini camp at
tours acl there's no need for that and
yeah if i'm jacksonville with trevor
lawrence right now like hey we do
one-on-ones you throw routes first air
you do some seven on seven anytime
there's an offense or defensive line
involved he's not involved i don't care
it's no contact right now somebody could
hit him he could fall on his left
shoulder and something can happen so you
keep him out of that that harm's way
until you really feel comfortable and
everything structurally sound that way
too
that graphic that was just on the screen
if you can bring that back
that is sobering
look at that jamarcus russell and
matthew stafford okay
but
yeah okay
sam bradford and yeah cam newton yes
andrew luck look he went 11-5 in his
first year but he's not in the league
anymore he decided to walk away james
winston six and ten jameis winston
competing to be the starter maybe in new
orleans jared goff and
it's it's it's just amazing now 2018
1920 mayfield murray and borough
all three so far are showing indications
that they're going to be on the right
side of pass fail but man even that
number one overall pick even when you've
got the clear shot and it's whoever you
want to choose off the board
it's far from a sure thing and i know we
regard trevor lawrence as a sure thing
but
history tells us yeah recent history
tells us that there is no sure thing
there is no sure thing but i think
that's what the love of trevor lawrence
and why you heard some of the
right the superlatives around him as in
general generational talent and all of
those type of things because
i think he is viewed a little
differently than most people on that
list i think a lot of people as we
talked about viewed him in the process a
lot like andrew luck that's how a lot of
people looked at him who obviously was
the the crown jewel as far as success
that rookie year after being a number
one pick
so
yeah i mean i i i get it i think trevor
lawrence the best thing about trevor
lawrence is he's he's got
unbelievable talent we all we've got all
the it factors everything like that but
there's still potential to grow as a
player and be better and the other thing
is i think where he's different than
most of that list there at least most of
it his his floor is so high like i
really think if trevor lawrence is like
a bust he's still going to be
jacksonville's starting quarterback for
eight years and be like in the middle of
the road as far as a starting
quarterback in the nfl like that's as
bad as it gets and i'd i'd just be
shocked if even it got that bad really
well i mean this is the franchise that
tolerated blake bortles has a starter
for five years yeah so what's eight
hit the bar the bar's low sorry sorry
blake yeah more hostile emails flowing
into the official pft
email inbox uh for that do you really
get that you get that stuff from those
comments there
i i hear from certain people whenever we
criticize blake bortles and i'm also
directly responsible for your assessment
yes of blake well that goes hand in hand
yeah i'm the edgar bergen and you're the
charlie mccarthy well make a very very
that makes no sense and i have no idea
who either one of those guys are old man
all right old timer all right well here
we go here comes music yep who is it
edward berger and who else did you say
i'll just i'll leave it to you chris to
research on your own time okay edgar
bergen
charlie mccarthy right that's it that's
all i'm gonna say um
the context should give you an idea of
what what it's referring to but i'll get
your burger
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports